- Breaking news, Crypto-Play
turned out to be a big scam.
In other news, the sky is blue
and those clowns in Congress did it again.
What a bunch of clowns.
- (chuckles) How's he keep
up with the news like that?
- Last week, FTX, the second
largest cryptocurrency exchange
in the world filed for bankruptcy.
- It's FTX.
I's a safe and easy
way to get into crypto.
- Eh, I don't think so.
- 2022 was a bad year for cryptocurrency,
but even in this volatile market,
FTX's sudden implosion
took people by surprise.
Many saw FTX as the
squeaky clean white knight
in the crypto world,
but with FTX in bankruptcy,
tens of billions of dollars,
AKA real money, missing
and giant holes in the balance sheet,
there's going to be hell to pay,
which is why lawyers are
the real white knights.
So what did FTX do wrong?
What laws might they have
broken and who is going to jail?
Or maybe it would be easier
to talk about who's not going to jail.
But hold on, folks.
We have a lot of ground to cover,
because there were probably
a lot of crimes broken.
FTX had over a million users
and was recently valued at $32 billion.
The company was founded in
2019 by Sam Bankman-Fried,
a 30-year-old ostensible wonder kid.
Bankman-Fried garnered lots of attention
for having a romantic relationship
with 10 other crypto people
and playing League of
Legends during meetings,
which apparently was a sign
of genius and business acumen.
And if so, I guess I need
to give my intern a raise.
But those warning signs didn't stop him
from securing massive investments
from some of the biggest
funders in Silicon Valley.
If anything, it helped
him procure that funding.
Foreshadowing!
But Bankman-Fried became the
darling of the crypto industry,
swooping into rescue
Robinhood and Voyager Digital
when they were struggling
earlier this year
and donating millions of
dollars to the Democratic Party.
And now, surprising no one,
BlockFi, which was rescued by FTX,
is now going bankrupt as well.
Sam Bankman-Fried, or
SBF, as he was known,
got his start at Jane Street,
a quantitative trading firm
that focused on arbitrage opportunities
in capital market flows.
After that, he started a hedge fund
called Alameda Research in 2017.
Bankman-Fried made his first fortune
by capitalizing on an
arbitrage opportunity
where he could buy crypto
coins at low prices in the U.S.
and sell them at much
higher price in Japan,
and in 2019, Bankman-Fried started FTX,
a crypto exchange which
set out to accommodate
the kind of trading that
he was doing at Alameda.
The exchange made fees
on the buying and selling
of different assets, some of
which are illegal in the U.S.
because they were too risky.
Again, more foreshadowing.
(thunder rumbles)
But that's one of the reasons
why FTX and other companies
were incorporated in The Bahamas,
and FTX and Alameda also spawned
a host of sister companies
that are involved in the bankruptcy.
Now, FTX became the second or
third largest crypto exchange
by volume, and often became
the lender of last resort
in many failed crypto projects.
Some called Bankman-Fried the
JP Morgan of the crypto world,
echoing the way that Morgan
had scooped up assets at low prices,
and Bankman-Fried often suggested
that he was going to buy
Goldman Sachs at one point.
Alas, that day is never going to come,
because reports now say that Bankman-Fried
may have improperly
transferred $10 billion
in customer money to his
hedge fund, Alameda Research,
and that at least $1 billion
of that money is missing.
Hackers made off with over
$400 million in tokens.
Some speculate that this
might have been an inside job.
And two weeks ago, the
company said that its tokens
were worth about $5.5 billion,
but the real value may have been
only in the hundreds of millions,
with less than $1
million in liquid assets.
Bankman-Fried was worth
$30 billion at one point,
but lost at least 94% of that
as it was wiped out in a single day.
And all this has regulators,
courts, and lawyers
circling FTX's corpse, so
there's already lawsuits
and it's possible that
everyone is going to jail.
And part of the reason
is that Bankman-Fried
allegedly started moving or lending
billions of dollars from
FTX, customer money,
to Alameda Research,
which suffered big losses
through risky trades.
Alameda put up FTX tokens, known as FTT,
as collateral for the loans.
This turned out to be problematic,
because FTX tokens weren't
widely traded outside of FTX
and were highly correlated
with the success or failure of FTX itself.
Now, we'll talk about
this more in a second,
but this is part of
the magic beans problem
that's inherent in a lot of
different crypto projects
throughout the entire industry.
And recently, FTX ran
into financial problems
and started shopping
around for investments.
Bankman-Fried sent investors a term sheet
that was a complete mess.
According to investors
who reviewed the pitch,
quote, "It contained hastily
arranged balance sheets,
mostly in unformatted Excel spreadsheets
that were replete with unformatted typos
and unnamed pages like Sheet 3.
No advisors or standard
information was included."
And because of the sloppy
nature of the balance sheet,
the data itself was questionable.
The balance sheet showed that
a lot of Alameda's assets
consisted of FTT, which is
the same name as FTX's tokens.
This meant that the tokens
were much less valuable
than previously thought.
Matt Levine of Bloomberg explains
why this is especially notable.
Quote, "The main attribute is that FTX
periodically uses a portion of its profits
to buy back FTT tokens.
This makes FTT kind of like stock in FTX.
The higher FTX's profits are,
the higher the price of FTT will be."
And as one Twitter user summarized it,
quote, "I created a
billion shares for my house
and sold one to my wife for $1,
valuing my house at $1 billion.
Give me $500 million please."
Now, throughout this whole affair,
FTX's main competitor was Binance.
Its CEO, Changpeng Zhao,
started talking trash
about FTT on Twitter,
saying, quote, "As part of Binance's exit
from FTX equity last year,
Binance received roughly
$2.1 billion USD equivalent
in cash, BUSD and FTT.
Due to recent revelations
that have come to light,
we've decided to liquidate any
remaining FTT on our books."
Now, the FTT tokens were
also the main liquid asset
FTX had to sell to pay
users making withdrawals,
so if a bunch of people lost faith in FTX
and wanted to take all their money out,
it would have to sell
its own cryptocurrency
to get the money.
And if people don't have
faith in your crypto exchange,
they probably don't have faith
in your cryptocurrency either,
so it might not be worth
enough to pay them back.
And as a result, FTX crashed
upon Zhao's announcement
that he was selling all of Binance's FTT,
causing the coin's value to plummet.
Then there was a bank run
or crypto exchange run,
in which retail investors
sought to withdraw their funds
at the same time, though in the aftermath,
Binance offered to buy FTX International
as sort of a bailout,
though Binance later
pulled out of the purchase,
solidifying the fact
that FTX was belly up.
This set off a chain reaction
as the rest of FTX users
tried to pull their money out,
but FTX didn't have their money,
or to the extent that
it had made investments,
those investments were illiquid.
And Bankman-Fried announced on Twitter
that it would be halting
non-fiat withdrawals.
Days later, FTX, Alameda,
and its associated companies
filed for Chapter 11 bankruptcy.
Now, Chapter 11 bankruptcy
is sometimes called
a reorganization bankruptcy,
and FTX's bankruptcy is complicated
because it includes
dozens of related entities
and shell companies.
Over 20 FTX companies have
bankruptcy petitions so far,
including Alameda Research.
The FTX entities filed slap
dash bankruptcy petitions,
asking the court to
impose an automatic stay
against the collection
of any outstanding debts,
but the picture got a little
clearer when FTX filed a motion
asking if it could file
a list of its 50 biggest
creditors by Friday.
In the motion, FTX said it could have
up to a million creditors,
probably mostly retail people.
It said, quote, "As set forth
in the debtor's petitions,
there are over 100,000 creditors
in these Chapter 11 cases.
In fact, there could be more
than 1 million creditors."
Many of these creditors
will be FTX customers.
In other bankruptcy
cases involving crypto,
customers have been designated
as unsecured creditors,
which means they will be last
in line for any repayment.
Now, two days after the
bankruptcy petitions,
FTX appointed a new CEO
to see the companies through
bankruptcy, John Ray.
Ray, who was previously
appointed chairman of Enron
after its bankruptcy,
stated in his declaration
in support of FTX's Chapter 11 filing,
quote, "Never in my career have I seen
such a complete failure
of corporate controls
and such a complete absence
of trustworthy financial information.
From compromised systems integrity
and faulty regulatory oversight abroad
to the concentration of control
in the hands of a very small
group of inexperienced,
unsophisticated, and potentially
compromised individuals,
this situation is unprecedented."
This isn't a legal observation,
but that's definitely
not what you want to hear
from the guy that did
the unwinding of Enron.
So what else did we learn
from Ray's declaration?
Well, besides the fact that FTX companies
had poor to non-existent
corporate controls,
many of them also gave out
personal loans to their owners.
Bankman-Fried, for example,
got a $1 billion loan
from Alameda Research, and
some indications estimate
that the fair value of all the crypto
that FTX International holds
is less than a billion dollars,
far less than Bankman-Fried's evaluation
that FTX's holdings of FTT were
worth at least 5.5 billion.
The declaration also alleges
that FTX's financial statements
don't include customer liabilities.
Now, I'm not an expert in these things,
but I don't think that
meets GAP accounting.
And if it seems like Bankman-Fried
and his polycule members
didn't know what was going
on, that's probably because,
quote, "The FTX group did not maintain
centralized control of its cash.
Cash management procedural failures
included the absence of an accurate list
of bank accounts and account signatories,
as well as insufficient attention
to the credit worthiness
of banking partners around the world."
I know it's hard to believe,
but these crypto people
might have made some
bad financial decisions.
Now, furthermore, Ray attests that, quote,
"In The Bahamas, I understand
that corporate funds
of the FTX group were
used to purchase homes
and other personal items
for employees and advisors."
And while Ray has been pouring over
the bankruptcy financials,
Bankman-Fried has spent a lot of his time
tweeting apologies for his
mistakes and giving interviews,
which is not a great legal move there.
And one interview was a text chain
between Bankman-Fried and a FOX reporter,
in which he tells her
that his public beliefs
in effective altruism
were basically just PR.
He said he didn't mean
to do unethical things,
but, quote, "Each individual
decision seemed fine,
and I didn't realize how big
their sum was until the end."
And the end result is that
these FTX companies are insolvent,
and complicating things further,
there's the second bankruptcy
filed by the Bahamian FTX Company,
which claims to be the primary bankruptcy,
filing for Chapter 15 bankruptcy.
And in fighting those
jurisdictional claims,
the original Delaware bankruptcy lawyers
are claiming that the government
officials in The Bahamas
are engaging in all kinds of corrupt acts
and are basically colluding
with Sam Bankman-Fried.
It's a giant mess.
But bankruptcy isn't their only problem.
The the companies will
have to deal with U.S.
and foreign regulators,
lawsuits from consumers,
and even criminal enforcement actions.
So there's little doubt
that the government
is now investigating, but
there are two U.S. agencies
that are vying to regulate crypto,
and probably this case in particular:
The Securities in Exchange
Commission, the SEC,
and the Commodity Futures
Trading Commission, or CFTC.
Now, if crypto is a security,
then it falls under the
jurisdiction of the SEC,
but if it's a commodity,
then the CFTC gets involved.
Now, the CFTC has exclusive jurisdiction
over accounts, agreements,
and transactions
involving swaps or contracts of sale
of a commodity for future delivery.
The CFTC has asserted jurisdiction
over fraud and manipulation
involving spot market transactions
relating to commodities which
underlie futures or swaps.
The CFTC first determined that Bitcoin
and other virtual currencies
were properly defined as
commodities back in 2015,
and the CFTC ruled that, "people
who had created a platform
for the purchase and
sale of Bitcoin options
were actually operating a facility
for the trading or processing of swaps
without being registered as
a swap execution facility
or designated contract market."
The CFTC then initiated
an enforcement actions,
focusing on classic cases
of fraud and Ponzi schemes.
Now, courts are still deciding
whether digital tokens
are securities or not.
They do this according to the HOWEY Test,
which refers to the
1946 Supreme Court case
in which the the Supreme
Court set forth a framework
for deciding whether an
investment contract exists,
which states, quote, "There
must be an investment of money
or other assets and a common enterprise
with the expectation of profit
to be derived from the efforts of others.
The absence of one prong will prove fatal
to a finding that an investment
is an investment contract."
And the SEC recently stated,
quote, "The main issue
in analyzing a digital
asset under the HOWEY Test
is whether the purchaser
has a reasonable expectation
of profits or other financial returns
derived from the efforts of others."
And while this is certainly up in the air,
I think it's likely that
courts are going to say
that cryptocurrencies fall under
the category of securities.
So FTX executives could be prosecuted
under U.S. securities laws.
The company may have violated
the Securities Exchange
Act of 1934, Rule 10-B,
which makes it illegal to
directly or indirectly use
any measure to defraud,
make false statements,
omit relevant information,
or otherwise conduct business operations
that would deceive another person
in the process of conducting transactions
involving stock and other securities.
And traditionally, violations of Rule 10-B
have included insider trading,
as well as defrauding
investors by hiding losses
or low revenue with creative
accounting practices.
And that's not even including
the possible violations
of myriad different state laws
for fraud or misappropriation as well.
And although FTX was
headquartered in The Bahamas,
eventually, the company sold
products to American consumers,
so if you're raising assets
from American customers,
you're placing yourself
within the jurisdiction of U.S. laws.
And one of the main issues
that looks just super bad,
that's a legal term,
is that FTX loaned customer
money to Alameda Research.
It's reported that customers
did not know that FTX
was using their funds to make
financially risky trades.
When customers sought
to withdraw their money,
they discovered that their
funds were not available.
And there's another interesting
wrinkle to the scheme,
which is that Alameda would
then buy up FTT tokens
to prop up FTX.
This makes the entire enterprise
look more and more like a Ponzi scheme,
where both FTX and Alameda were
looking out for each other,
but neither of them were
helping their investors,
though potentially some
of the liability here
will depend on the
contracts with customers
and between the different companies.
You can't disclaim fraud in a contract,
but it's possible that
some of the customers
might have affirmatively
agreed to some of this behavior
by agreeing to the terms and
conditions of the exchange.
But does this mean that company executives
could be charged with crimes?
Well, let's start with the
most obvious one, wire fraud.
Wire fraud is a type of fraud
involving the use of
telecommunications or the internet.
Wire fraud could include any
form of electronic media,
including email, social
media, text messages,
or even good old-fashioned fax machines.
If the defendant used
interstate telephone calls
or electronic communications,
then the government can prosecute.
And under 18 USC 1343,
there are four elements
to classic wire fraud:
One, that the defendant
voluntarily and intentionally
devised or participated in a scheme
to defraud another out of money;
two, that the defendant did
so with the intent to defraud;
three, that it was reasonably foreseeable
that interstate wire
communications would be used;
and four, that interstate
wire communications
were, in fact, used.
So, based on what we know,
could Bankman-Fried be
prosecuted for wire fraud?
Well, the DOJ probably faces
two large hurdles to prosecution.
The first would be jurisdictional.
FTX and its associated companies
are incorporated in The Bahamas,
and up until recently, most
executives lived there,
and they would argue that the DOJ
doesn't have jurisdiction
to prosecute them.
But prosecutors could
overcome this defense
if they can show that there's a nexus
between FTX and the United States.
Prosecutors would say that FTX
does lots of business in America.
It has customers in the
U.S., it uses American banks,
its executives frequently
travel to the U.S. and further
of the crypto business,
and it's safe to assume that the DOJ
could probably clear that
jurisdictional hurdle.
Now, the second problem
for the DOJ is intent.
Section 1343 requires
proof that the defendant
acted with the intent to defraud,
that is, the intent to deceive and cheat.
So if Bankman-Fried did a bad
job of managing the company,
that's not a crime.
The government would have to prove
that he did it on purpose.
Now, Coinbase CEO Brian
Armstrong said that he believed
that Bankman-Fried did commit fraud.
Like FTX, Coinbase is a crypto exchange,
and Armstrong said that he spoke
with both Sam Bankman-Fried
and Binance CEO Changpeng Zhao,
who briefly considered buying FTX,
and during those conversations,
Armstrong got the impression
that FTX knowingly
improperly used customer
funds to prop up Alameda.
- You know, FTX was in a position where
they had this market maker, Alameda,
that was investing in risky
things, and that's fine.
Like, market makers, hedge funds,
they're designed to take more risk.
So it seems they had this solvency issue,
and instead of just letting it blow up,
Sam basically said, hey,
we have a bunch of customer
assets over here at FTX,
or he somehow basically made
a loan from FTX into Alameda
to try to prop it up.
I don't know why he did that.
I mean, that's the moment, in my mind,
where he crossed the line into
probably committing fraud.
And I think he probably lied
to users, lied to investors,
and he went around and tried to bail out
these different companies,
like Voyager and BlockFi,
to sort of prop up this thing,
and maybe he thought he could
trade his way out of it.
- So FTX customers
believed that their crypto
was immediately accessible,
but according to Armstrong,
FTX used customer assets
to fund the operating
expenses of the company.
But FTX's terms of service seem
to clearly prohibit
lending on those assets.
It says, quote, "None of the
digital assets in your account
are the property of or shall
or may be loaned to FTX Trading.
FTX Trading does not represent
or treat digital assets
in users' accounts as
belonging to FTX Trading."
So the government will assess
all of Bankman-Fried's
statements and the actions
to figure out if he was
just in over his head
or whether he knew he
was defrauding customers.
John Ray accused the companies
of commingling assets
using company money for personal projects
and using software to hide
their moves from consumers.
All of that goes to Bankman-Fried's
intent to commit fraud,
so I asked former SEC
prosecutor Ron Geffner
about this whole situation.
- With regard to FTX,
there appear to be many
misrepresentations and acts of fraud
based on the facts that
are currently available.
The conduct that seems
to be most egregious
are material misrepresentations
as to user funds
and where the money was being sent into,
where it theoretically was being held
on behalf of consumers and investors.
It would appear that
corporate governance at FTX
was, at the very least,
we can all agree, sloppy.
It may have risen to the level
where corporate governance was fraudulent,
and the fact that there
were conflicts of interest,
there were misrepresentations made
to both the public and to
both private investors.
The public and private
investors made decisions
based on false factual information.
Whether the principles of FTX
will be prosecuted criminally
it's gonna depend on whether
the U.S. justice system
has standing in any case against FTX,
given much of their
behavior occurred offshore.
It is out of my wheelhouse, but
based on patterns I've seen,
even if investors recover
any kind of remuneration or their assets,
I have to imagine it would
be pennies on the dollar.
The takeaway I would have is
pessimism is a good thing,
no matter what you're investing in.
It's why do I have this opportunity?
What is the opportunity?
What is the upside and
what is the downside risk?
And in many cases, as human beings,
when we assess what is
the worst case scenario,
we rarely ever really
assess what is worst case.
We usually assess what's a bad case,
but not what is the worst case.
And it goes back to, if you
don't understand, don't invest,
and if you can't afford
to lose it all, then,
theoretically, don't invest in
these types of opportunities.
- Now, that's not the
end of the story here,
because FTX promoted itself and
created an air of legitimacy
by associating with
celebrities like Tom Brady,
Giselle Bundchen, Shaquille O'Neal,
Larry David, and Naomi Osaka,
and those people have now
been sued by investors
in a headline-grabbing
class action lawsuit
Edwin Garrison is the named plaintiff
who had an FTX yield-bearing account
which he funded with crypto
assets to earn interest.
Now, Sam Bankman-Fried is the
lead defendant in this case,
but investors are also suing
those celebrity promoters,
and Garrison alleges that,
while FTX lured U.S. investors
to its yield bearing
accounts, it was, quote,
"a Ponzi scheme where investor funds
were shuffled into related entities
to maintain the appearance of liquidity."
And while this lawsuit made headlines,
it's going to be a really uphill battle
to recover from the celebrity endorsers.
Plaintiffs allege that defendants violated
the Florida Investor's Protection Act,
and the law extends
liability to any director,
officer, partner, or
agent of or for the seller
if the director, officer,
partner, or agent
has personally participated
or aided in making the sale.
But it's not clear that
a celebrity endorsement
makes them an agent of the
seller for purposes of this act.
It's also not clear that
advertising for the FTX Exchange,
or even, theoretically,
its yield bearing accounts,
qualifies as a security under the act.
And as we discussed above,
it's unclear whether crypto
itself is a security,
but advertising for the exchange
rather than a specific security
adds yet another level of
distraction for the celebrities.
And similarly, these lawsuits' claims
for unfair trade practices,
which relies on an underlying liability,
or civil conspiracy, which
requires an agreement,
would be extraordinarily hard to prove
against the celebrity endorsers.
Though one wrinkle here
is that both Tom Brady
and Gisele Bundchen are
reported to have taken
a huge equity stake in FTX,
which actually might change the result.
- [Gisele] What do you think?
Are you in?
- You know what?
I'm in.
- Now, a lot of people want to know
whether FTX customers are going
to see any kind of recovery,
whether through lawsuits
or as unsecured creditors
in the bankruptcy process.
And Chapter 11 has been around for forever
and has a solid process,
but, unfortunately,
U.S. bankruptcy courts
don't have much experience
handling bankruptcy claims
of crypto companies.
Two crypto lending companies,
Celsius and Voyager Digital,
filed for bankruptcy
protection earlier this year,
and customer assets are still frozen.
So it'll take lots of
time, probably years,
to determine whether FTX
customers can recover anything.
And in fact, the Mt. Gox
bankruptcy is eight years old
and is still ongoing.
And the fact that crypto
is largely unregulated
means that customers aren't protected
by the same kinds of safeguards that exist
when banks and other brokerage firms fail.
Now, if you invested in FTX,
you'd probably benefit
from an exclusive class
I made for Nebula called
How to Sue Like a Lawyer.
It's 90 minutes of information and jokes
about the legal system, which you'll need
if you actually want to get
your money back from FTX,
and it's available only on
today's sponsor, Nebula.
On Nebula, my videos come
out early with zero ads,
and I release exclusive
content all the time,
like an entire video about legal stories
that are not safe for work
and are too hot for YouTube,
which is, unfortunately,
too hot for YouTube,
my first full-length documentary,
"Bad Law Words Good,"
and two full-length classes,
plus tons more, all exclusive to Nebula.
And there's other amazing
exclusive content,
like "Jet Lag: The Game,"
which is basically like
"The Amazing Race,"
but for creators, and is honestly
my favorite thing on
the internet right now.
Or if you want to learn more
about the FTX situation,
you could watch ColdFusion's
videos on FTX ad-free.
And on Nebula, you get Nebula-first videos
released way early, zero
ads, Nebula Originals,
and now, for the first time,
when you sign up for Nebula directly,
you get Nebula Classes,
which is a $150 value.
Nebula is creator-owned
and all of the creators on
the platform share equity,
and we've been developing
Nebula like crazy.
It now has apps for
iOS, Android, Apple TV,
Roku, Fire TV, and Android TV.
Now, Nebula is normally $50 a year,
but you can sign up directly with the link
that's onscreen right now
or in the description
and you can get 20% off.
That's $40 for the entire year,
now with Nebula Classes.
It's the best way to support Legal Eagle,
but what's more, signing
up will actually help
countless independent educational creators
beyond just Legal Eagle.
So sign up now by clicking on the link
that's onscreen right now,
or click on the link that's
down below in the description.
Get a huge discount for Nebula,
and after that, click
on this box over here
for more Legal Eagle, or
I'll see you in court.